please welcome ben schwartz hard ben
oh my god we're wearing the same flower
this is insane
oh i'm so embarrassed i'm mortified
i love your accoutrement oh thank you
hello ross how are you i'm fantastic now
i want a flower thanks a lot
you have a big sunflower look oh i do
what would be perfect
you have the biggest flower of us all uh
thanks for noticing
ben this was the first time you were
actually playing a father
and you're not a father in real life
tell me about that because i have felt
the
same way it was fun look at that kid
look how that's matilda lawler
who was on broadway before she did this
movie and she's incredible so it made
the whole process
amazing first day i like to i took my
tilde and threw her really high in the
air she held on to the rafters and was
like
what am i doing and i did all the wrong
dad things we were it was terrible
but then we got a hang of it it was
great all right ben will you do some
headlines with us
i can't wait i don't know what's about
to happen and i'm so thrilled
i can't wait we're gonna start with one
that i think you'll be able to get
behind right the boston globe reports
that typewriters
are making a comeback business is
booming
for the little shop called cambridge
typewriter
and sales are up by 40 and a lot of
younger people are coming in
looking for an old clickety clacker ben
what are your thoughts this is gonna
blow everything but i'm not really at a
news desk
i have a series i have two different
typewriters oh
i love typewriters it's like one of my
favorite things
do you actually use them like you when
you write
i you probably use it maybe twice a week
i send my friends
uh letters and i pretend i'm either them
from the past that sent them a letter
from
like or it's their grandparents or if my
friend talks trash about like an nba
player on twitter
i'll pretend i'm that nba player and
lebron james will send that person a
note be like
how dare you make fun of me on twitter
and stuff like that
so it's been very not to be pushy but
maybe we could be pen pals i want to
hear about
what my past and i like writing letters
i'm a big snail mailer wait
you give me an address you will get a
letter asap i can't wait till you get a
letter from i know me too
i hope it was okay i just was like ben
we're gonna write each other
it's gonna be great it's good well this
is exciting because next we're talking
peanut butter passion and today's food
news
okay delish reports that a recent survey
asked people if they are a
creamy peanut butter person or
a crunchy peanut butter person and it
was split right down the middle 50-50
but people were so passionate that half
of them said they wouldn't even
date someone who liked the other kind
and to that i say
come on the paul also looked at peanut
butter personalities
listen to this creamy types are early
birds and more introverted
and crunchies are extroverted night owls
well i i feel very strongly about peanut
butter i love it and i
buy creamy because that's just what i
know but whenever i have crunchy i feel
like such a bad boy
you know what i mean yeah right jacket
to go out at night
yeah can i also give a follow-up
question to you guys
what are your thoughts on tiny spoons i
love a tiny spoon
love a tiny spoon i think about this
literally every day
because i do my yogurt parfait in the
morning and i have this one tiny spoon
one of them and i will have to wash it
every single morning
because it's my only tiny spoon you
gotta buy another one ross you earned it
you deserve it
um here's a tip don't eat peanut butter
on television um
ben are you crunchy or creamy are you
nice or naughty
i could do both i love i love both
sometimes one of my things when i'm
filming
if my energy's getting low is i get a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich on
whole wheat
and i usually use creamy for that yeah i
think for a sandwich it's too much
combativeness with the bread
you need creamy but i just bought a jar
in your mouth you cover your mouth when
you're true you're so polite
ross and i are absolute dogs
rabid dogs eating
i told you it's for bad boys
[Laughter]
what are you are you creamy or crunchy
i'm both
i'm a straddler
[Laughter]
i'm naughty and nice as you as you've
been
like one side has taken over more or no
oh once side definitely takes every more
sometimes
i get real crunchy sometimes
um but then i get also really creamy
sometimes
i could be like super packed with
peanuts but also i could have none
in me none i am with you ben
and i think you play a fantastic father
in flora and ulysses
it's available right now on disney plus
and um ben we have unfinished business
clickety clack send them i'll
and you'll respond to me or this will be
very embarrassing i'll never get a
response no no
pen pals is a two-way street i'm gonna
smear like peanut butter on the inside
so you know it's me so tell people not
to be weirded out if it's like an
envelope
like with a half peanut butter in it it
might be the new sealant we were all
looking for
that'll make you want to lick the
envelopes all right thank you ben
so much we'll be in touch
[Music]